we went to [ __ ] london dude
we went to london oh [ __ ] dude we
[ __ ] absolutely went to london we
infiltrated london that's what we did oh
[ __ ] we were two americans infiltrating
london oh [ __ ] dude
ah we saw big ben oh [ __ ] we saw it from
the plane and we saw it from the london
eye oh for [ __ ] sake we also saw it
from the ground oh god
they saw it three different ways jesus
christ they saw it from above from below
and absolutely in the middle of for
[ __ ] sake dude
that's just absolute but we saw big ben
and b guess what we learned big ben
doesn't even [ __ ] refer to the clock
it refers to whatever something [ __ ]
inside the clock oh for [ __ ] sake and
he saw it from all different angles and
even though he saw it from all different
angles kristen kept saying look and he
and he did every time oh god damn it
even though he saw it he kept getting
the [ __ ] hey look
but it's all good dude we took the
london eye and that was the most
touristy [ __ ] we did too uh we went to
london and i got to the airport and um
they [ __ ] canceled we were in that
american airlines thing that just
canceled all of our flights this is
going to be the best episode ever dude i
have so much to talk about i can't wait
to get it we have a lot to discuss like
when news when [ __ ] programs you know
we got a lot to discuss here and then
they just talk about like rihanna's
dress
you know i can't wait to get into this
actually because we have a lot to go
over um
the guy who hosts [ __ ] whatever that
show is what was he wearing um so uh
uh blake who's the country singer the
[ __ ] guy
blake shelton the most [ __ ] guy he's
never felt a level of insecurity at all
just always [ __ ] just like what oh
who cares man they don't like me that's
great
you don't like this outfit oh [ __ ] man
whatever maybe i'll wear it again maybe
i won't you know [ __ ] you know i
guess if i want to i will
[ __ ]
how much has you [ __ ] eight women um
in his life um so
yeah dude
so the guy says so i get to the airport
american airlines was just all of a
sudden they go flight's cancelled
great so we go online what do we do no
wait sorry we were at the airport and
the flight got canceled kristin goes hey
look look what happened she got a text
cancel dude go to the desk now i'm ready
you know me i'm rip roaring right you
know me i'm rip roar and i'm ready to go
but she says com you know maybe this is
gonna be a good she's got this new
saying that is like an old saying that's
like good news bad news who knows bad
news good news who knows and they're
like sometimes bad news is good news you
just have no [ __ ] idea and i'm like
okay too fair enough you know
so uh i go up and do the guy couldn't
have been nicer and i kept it cool and
it couldn't have been nicer the guy at
jetblue it's called jetblue y or some
[ __ ] [ __ ] why why it's called
like jetblue it's like a station of jet
blue that they have
where you go and everything's [ __ ] up
it's not called like you like uh
customer service they call it some [ __ ]
like why did this happen or something
jetblue how come i don't even know what
it's called jetblue oops it's called
[ __ ] i don't know what it is but we
went to the desk
and this lady did the thing where even
though i was first you cut a line and it
was fine whatever because everyone's all
[ __ ] and i was like what are we gonna
do dude and we had a layover in jfk and
instead dude they gave us a [ __ ]
straight shot dude they made up for it
straight shot baby
so we did it got to london
in the airport dude i was in the airport
and i was like i'm gonna go get some
water and i go to get a [ __ ] i could
get that smart water you know
so the guy at the thing
he was like this dude that was making so
many jokes to people
and he says to me
i get there and he says now has
anyone told you
and i go here we go
here we go
and it's all good
this is the life that i lead here we go
and he says has anyone told you
something you don't know before
and i said
it was one of those sentence that
it felt like
oh
oh okay so
this is not okay somebody whoops
somebody stole my brain
i i
i'm just
what's going on i'm looking for my brain
because here's the thing that sentence
is one of those things that like when
you you know when you look at those
paintings with the artist and they do
like they do paintings of like somebody
with two sets of eyes and you're like
are there
you know
is there one or what if
it's just
it's like a thing like if you look up a
artist who puts two sets of eyes like
one right on top of each other it's like
a [ __ ] some artist does that and you
look at him and you're just like is it
and you know there's four eyes but
you're still like there's two wait it's
my mind is just
or like they'll have like does this
shape fit in this thing or this thing
and you're like well that one's way
smaller but it fits in both and you're
like but how does
what is it and it's like an optical
illusion
but for
four words he did it he didn't this
[ __ ] did an optical illusion
with words dude he says has anyone told
you something you don't know before and
at first i think well
uh
yeah
because
all that would be is like hey you know
flounders have two eyes on only one side
of their body and no eyes on the other
oh
that's something i didn't know before
somebody told me that or i read it
so yes
but then i think
but the only answer to that is yes
because no matter who you are somebody's
told you something you don't know before
so it can't be what he means right
unless
somebody stole my brain
and i just can't figure it out so
instead
i feel like i i realize the only thing
that i can possibly say to this man
is what
because then surely
he'll clear it up
so he says to me has anyone told you
something you don't know before
and then i quickly assess the situation
with the brain that is still in my head
and i hit him with
what
and then he says
has anyone told you
something you don't know before
so now
i'm [ __ ]
because
he doubled down
this is what he meant
but surely he's behind a counter so he
deals with people and deals with things
and situations so he's capable i guess
and i'm just holding the [ __ ] smart
water
and so i say
well
what
do you mean
and he
says you really resemble keanu reeves
and i say oh yeah well
i have heard that before
and he says yeah
and i said well that's not so bad he's
cool and he says yeah
hey guy
just tell me i look like keanu reeves
has anyone told you something that's
when my friend walked up to this [ __ ]
chick and he and he meant to say like
hey
have we met before or something or
whatever instead he wrote he walked up
to her and said do you know who i am
right now dude and we never forgot it
man do you know who i am right now
jake but also i'm always jake um
dude i went into the pool the other day
i feel like here's the thing dude i have
an assistant and some and she uses our
pool sometimes which is [ __ ] radical
i love it because the pool gets used
and uh she told me that the [ __ ] uh
pool guy was like
oh there's a shortage on chlorine and
like whatever dude there there's always
a shortage on everything now ever since
covid and they making it up half the
time you know they're making it up
they'll be like there's a shortage on
[ __ ] there's actually a shortage on
coca-cola or [ __ ] water you know and
you're like really yeah there's a
shortage on cardboard boxes ever since
got it you can't get anything if you
want to get
so there's a shortage on chlorine so i
just got to take it because i don't know
what am i going to pretend i know more
about pools than this [ __ ] so
i'm like okay well when when can we get
it he's like probably a month or two i
said can we swim in our pool and he says
sure it's fine it's not a big deal and
it's gonna have like a big party and
just don't [ __ ] in it
then i say well you know about the anus
thing like sometimes just with your
anuses if you got a little diarrhea in
it on your ink sometimes the anus has
[ __ ] pebbles on it you can't help it and
then it's just in the pool what if it's
in there and it goes well it's fine you
know just don't be [ __ ] in the pool
so i'm like all right cool we won't get
in the pool but i have a two-year-old i
gotta make sure he's not [ __ ] in the
pool
and we get [ __ ] you know we all get
[ __ ] up but
i get in the pool and i get to pull with
calvin the next day boom i wake up my
uvula is swollen yes dude
yes
my uvula is swollen now does that sound
for those of you that don't know what a
uvula is does it sound like something
that resides in a course it does is it
no it's the back thing in the [ __ ] that
hangs out from the back of your [ __ ]
okay in the mouth when you all the
cartoons when they go ah and the camera
looks in it you see that your dangling
that little [ __ ] that that [ __ ] uh
what do you call it the the the boxing
[ __ ] the speed bag that little speed
bag in the back your mouth that's called
the uvula it doesn't reside in the put
resides in your mouth the only time it
resides in a put
i guess is when someone's being bored
because they have a uv layer in their
mouth but anyway
too far
but anyway
so um
this is gonna be restricted this video
but it's all good my babies share it
with somebody share it with somebody but
that was also medical and science and
this is a uvula and they do reside where
i said before if they didn't catch me
the first time but they resided where
they said before
uh where i said before so i get out of
the pool the next day i wake up swelling
you of your life yes dude [ __ ] yeah man
whoa
and i say to my assistant great i got a
[ __ ] thing from the algae in my pool
and she's like she laughs you know cause
she knows me she's like he didn't get
the [ __ ] thing from that algae in
your pool and i was like okay well i'm
just saying dude they got a chlorine
shortage and the [ __ ] pool guy's
being lazy and he can't hook us up with
the chlorine [ __ ] it's like it's crack
cocaine we gotta find a new guy a new
dealer
and we can't get it in the pool
and uh she's like it's fine
so okay so a few weeks go by i get in
the pool again dude the day before we go
to london i wake up
[ __ ] yeah dude got a speed bag in the
back of my mouth again
swollen uvula time baby
swollen [ __ ] uvula time dude this
time it's fat as [ __ ] dude this time
i can lay it flat on the back of my
tongue it looks like jabba the hut okay
your boy's got a swollen uvula it's
disgusting but i go okay last time it
lasted a day let's hope it only lasts a
day because then i'm going to be nervous
about bringing covert to [ __ ]
to all the people who [ __ ] you know
because your boy went to london
i got [ __ ] covered i'm spreading
covered all around different angles of
[ __ ] big pen you know i don't want
that right
the next day i wake up yuval is gone so
she says and all of a sudden my
assistant just says it's not the pool i
said well it's just a coincidence that
it happened two times and she said look
if it happens four times then it maybe
is your pull and i was like what what
the [ __ ] you just making some [ __ ] up
willy nilly she's like four times means
that so i'll let you know next two times
if i got a [ __ ] speed back that's
just relaxing on the back of my tongue
dude
like jabba the hutt after i get out the
pool because chlorine there's a chlorine
shortage
i don't know it's like has anyone told
you something that you don't know before
so uh that's what's been happening in my
life and then i get to the [ __ ] thing
and there's a flight delay dude and i'm
at the flight delay and dude check this
out they got we do we got the straight
shot but so i had a first the first leg
of my [ __ ]
was the guy was so helpful dude he was
super helpful the first leg of my [ __ ]
was
la
to
jfk and then the second and that was
jetblue mint we sit back we relax we
have a good time we go we go horizontal
if i can't go horizontal in a flight i
ain't going all right yeah it costs bags
but dude
okay there's the difference between
being uncomfortable when you arrive and
[ __ ] being super spry and cool and
keeping it nice and in a good mood
because you laid horizontal right
um
so we get a
all the way to jfk we land and then we
got aboard an american airlines flight
from jfk to heathrow ally okay now
we
all the american airlines did something
happen with their computer and like
overnight they canceled 12 000 flights
in june
or july
12 000 flights in july they just
canceled them got all [ __ ] up we all
have to rebook so i go to the [ __ ]
jet blue oopsy daisy or whatever the
[ __ ] the thing is called did you look it
up what it's called
jet blue how come jet blue oops jet blue
wow that's what the sign says get dink
oops um
so uh
i get to i get to the thing and he's
like um
okay so the flight's canceled canceled
we're gonna miss our connection so so
what do we do and i'm ready for him so
this is your fault so what do we do and
he says oh god and i go great and he
says
we don't have another flight to london
for another two days and i say well at
that point we'll just have to come back
around immediately so what are we gonna
do and he says let me look you know what
i can do you know what it's a connecting
flight let me actually see
if i can call them
to
in jfk to hold the flight until you land
and i say
what
and he says
so in some cases i i'm able to call
and have them hold up a plane
if you're not going to make a connection
or something like that
and i'm like
is this a
famous thing or
[Music]
he says sometimes we can do it and i say
and it's like legal and
you guys can actually do this you've
done it before and he says oh yeah
and i'm like
oh
airlines are full of [ __ ]
sorry we can't open the door you're late
oh no you're full of [ __ ] i just found
out dude because some really nice gay
man behind the [ __ ] jet blue oopsy
daisy station told me that you can hold
up a [ __ ] flight just cause
oh sorry we closed the door oh no no no
no have you ever been to jetblue oopsy
daisy in lax in terminal five no you
haven't talked to the very nice gay man
probably and ask him to hold up the
plane
open the door
i don't know if you know that they can
do that but they can do that dude and
then i came back and asked my assistant
about it because she used to be a flight
attendant and she said yes they can do
that and i go where's everyone hiding
this information dude it's [ __ ]
crazy
crazy
crazy
crazy
[Music]
crazy